welcome to this video playing my way
from Norway yeah um and with lighter I
usually have like somehow against him
okay let's go for that an open position
he has a weird way of playing that was
g6 andy sixx which it's not really great
but i am not really getting that farm in
many games okay playing a 3 here by the
way I've got minus 1 against him 11.5
from 24 11 wins 12 losses one drawer
yeah we usually get sharp games
interesting games Gabby should be seven
then I go g3 that is a well-known
theoretical nine after d5 it will be an
yet isolated twin pond cd5 bd5 know he's
doing this okay huh what is the right
way here 24 i guess that looks quite
normal let's do that oh damn probably a
couple of options
a mighty maybe just you can probably
just go back am yeah that's true ok I
don't really have a good scrap with the
Queen okay I don't want to draw it's
just that I didn't see what else to do
then going back now i can try c5 yeah
that's an interesting move
I wonder if Quinn c7 s is something if I
go nite be five then years Quincy 6am
that's a very embarrassing moment but
after Queen c7 I have um some norman was
let's say yeah this one I was thinking
at this should be good huh and then
Bishop f4 Luke b8 Bishop f4 isn't that
good looks really bad for black maybe
yes to go back to c6 now has to go back
to c6 and down what that isn't brilliant
for black kids not it's not that i can
easily refute it at least i don't see
how mm-hmm maybe maybe that's not as bad
as it looks I don't see a clear way here
and forward
Bishop e3 might have no to form the
ticking looks weak but I didn't see him
an alternative if it goes d5 no i thinkI
for should be good ya know probably you
for attending you five I don't know
maybe whiteley slightly better but it's
not it's not simple or anything
and 93 and typically uncomfortable
especially as Bishop f4 absolutely bad
can I don't like that position what went
wrong here amazing he played that
strange opening and I did not do
anything anything great it seems really
strange John okay I mean it's not like
I'm gonna in bad shape or anything I
don't think so at least but I felt that
I should have some kind of an advantage
and it doesn't doesn't materialize at
all yeah that's a problem I don't want
to give up that Bishop really not okay
I'm threatening you five now song
again we can try it yogi I have to go
back I think and after this again
drallah is already a draw oh now I
wanted to actually deviate now but he
press the button that's stupid hard one
thanks no I wanted to continue am sorry
that just must be the first 20 move draw
in the history of the channel and it's
not it's not I was thinking maybe 94 or
something like that and just a but I was
I was really thinking it was just twice
and not a third time so um let's check
he went back here I go here and he does
that yeah he may be for him that that is
of course an idea to Steve form I
thought that this was interesting but it
doesn't seem to be that bad he has
played that night if I they went back
but if I have to check on on b6 not
really helping this is also given by the
comp yeah i know i can take maybe adds
an interesting line hmm yeah here it
seems to be that he's ok but the engine
wants to do this move yeah i was
thinking about it but here I couldn't
bring myself to play this which the
computer still likes for what it looks
really awkward but it's not I mean at
the moment Bishop c5 is not a problem
yeah probably it's ok yeah it's a bit
weird ever I'd still uploaded yet what a
weird game 2020 move draw but
yeah it was just just a mistake on my
part okay well thanks for watching